[Music]
every year the Commons allocates 75,000
pounds of public funds for new arts
works to grace the corridors of the
Palace of Westminster the paintings are
chosen by MPs they're often of MPs and
they're seen by very few people
yet the Commons is vetoing 500 thousand
pounds being spent on bringing the Big
Bend bomb to life at 11 p.m. on the 31st
of January to mark the moment the UK
finally leaves the EU the decision is
petty small-minded and cheapskates the
great Bell of course has been shut down
during refurbishment work on the
Elizabeth tower and the authorities have
estimated it cost five hundred thousand
pounds to bring it back to life not only
is five hundred thousand pounds
chickenfeed when you consider the 57
thousand pounds the government spent
stocking up its wine cellar in 2018 the
money can be raised from crowdfunding
the chimes of Big Ben will send a
distinctive signal across the world that
brexit has happened the bells will mark
the ushering in of a new era it's
something to celebrate
not to hide away the veto is yet another
sign that Parliament has never ever
signed up to the referendum result
[Music]
now I do I think it's fair to say the
Europe Lake City on you I think it's
better you're an archer I know I'm an
archer remaining and I I'm quite happy
to accept that we've lost right yeah but
why do you want to be so provocative why
do you all hope the whole government is
trying to say the whole government is
trying to say it's time to bring people
together and yet you and those like you
I would say no we won't I have great
celebrations I found this I I found this
in the Central Council of church bell
ringers which is amazing there is a
sense of council but they said they say
there are historical moments for which
bells have been run because it's not
just big Benesch bells across the
country isn't it the end the end of
world wars for example however the
central council does not endorse bell
ringing for political purposes and just
let it happen
yep but Greg I'm not calling for church
bells stirring I'm calling for one
distinctive iconic famous hanger Carroll
famous around the world there's going to
be thousands of people on Parliament
Square where I might had mass spec
cities had to run the gauntlet of your
lot with Klaxons and following you're
gonna be running that and Greg it will
last 12 12 Long's
12 seconds what's the big deal Harry and
Megan anything you say the ringing of
Big Ben is provocative Big Ben is the
symbols of our democracy and the brevard
result was the biggest democratic
decision this country has ever made this
is a history and the last time the bells
were wrong at a time just said was the
22 2012 olympics and this is way bigger
than that way more important than that
well can I just
yes say a couple of things yeah one the
examples that you gave a kind of false
comparisons 75,000 and 57,000 are
nowhere near
so do you know what 500,000 could pay
for a year do you tell me 22 nurses and
I like Greg I completely accept the
result remains shut up now it's done but
what I will say what I will say Andrea
is if you're saying this can be done
then race through crowds I think I've
got no problem how much is the
crowdfunding race just by the way I
don't believe the figure of 500,000 why
should it cost so much
let me just get the man whose table the
question is trying to get to the bottom
is it's the Conservative MP mark
Francois
we will launch a national crowdfunding
campaign probably tomorrow that Big Ben
will bond for brexit and then people who
wish to donate to that it's entirely
voluntary can do so there'll be a slight
sense of urgency because there's a lead
time to make the preparations for the
bell to chime so realistically we need
to raise the money by the weekend this
does actually provide an opportunity for
a bit of closure those that want to
celebrate should celebrate maybe a few
people wake up in the morning with a bit
of a hangover and then we can all move
forward as a nation I vow to myself and
actually now stay on my OBC show at the
end of the year that I will stop
debating brixon yeah and so as a result
cuz I lost right so as a result have
your Big Ben but as you just heard
you've got one day left to raise the
five hundred thousand pounds
good luck I'll tell you why
don't actually know how to cry for but
it soon it shows me I do it is the
problem what is the problem for this
iconic clock chiming for 12 seconds go
why are you so Posey is it cuz it just
remind you it's 47,000 pounds of ring
five hundred thousand pound total
because they've got to install a floor a
temporary floor to then get the bell
back up they could have left the
temporary floor there from when they
rang December the 30,000 pounds of
reason for the delay in the construction
that even caused and then and you've got
one day left to raise it if that can all
be done yeah then this is great okay I
want to hear what our Prime Minister has
to say about this the bonds cost five
hundred thousand pounds police because
yeah but we're working up a plan so that
people can bung a bob for being bed bong
because there is there some people who
want to developing policy lines nobody
this because everybody knows Big Ben is
being refurbished they've taken you see
they seem to have taken the clapper away
so we need to restore the clapper in
order to bong Big Ben
on Betsy tonight Big Ben is the
heartbeat to our capital I think that
was unfortunate but is a very remainer
put a quid in would have seventeen and a
half million quid who could keep it
bangin for a whole week banging a bogey
are you gonna get him a lot 5p v Ferrari
started it off with a grexit Tsar in
chief the Prime Minister right you let
the brexit care even
saying it's costing 500 there there are
problems and we've got the wherewithal
and the wit work out how to make a club
which I'm going to bring big bit just
because of you Greg I have to say we're
gonna ring those bells come what may and
they don't I will be Big Ben a bit of
insta
but there's no easy route to social
media content success as Judy Murray
found out this week the tennis coach
posted a picture of what she thought was
a funny joke on the gram the caption
read how to say hello in Mandarin but
the poster didn't prompt the flurry of
likes and juicy comments she was hoping
for
instead this response from son Andy left
a rather more bitter taste hi mum you've
done it again Instagram is a visual
platform so if you post a picture with
half the content cut out it doesn't work
you will get less likes and people will
unfollow you probably a wise decision on
their part this just looks like a few
mandarins
scattered on a table who wouldn't want
people to think you're a mad old lady
please try to do better love from your
baby boy PS this is your final warning
before I unfollow that is definitely
game set and match to the tennis star
for serving that slice of reality Andy
Murray you are our straight talker of
the week
you even be Andrews worse I think that
was quite Sweden quite funny for people
is he's not known for you to be really
cold
you always gotta turn it believe in you
together
that was good no that was good
anyway that's it this week on the pledge
but you can join in the debate by
searching for us on Twitter and if you
want to listen on the go just search for
the pledge podcast on Spotify Apple
podcasts or the sky news app thanks for
watching that we'll see you next time
[Music]